welcome back to the realest podcast in
the dunya
today i'm joined
by myself with a very special guest
someone who's been uh requested to come
on a few times from a few different
people
and that is none other than jake the
muslim metaphysician salaamwalekum bro
how are you doing bro alhamdulillah
i'm goddess it's good to have you man
you have uh the muslim metaphysician
version of the like the mega hat
yeah that's right bro was that on
purpose
no not really man um i read is just my
favorite color and i
i just bought the hat online
and um i just stuck with it and the
first time i went live with it people
were like dude are you a trump supporter
[Laughter]
and i'm like no i didn't even think
about it yeah that's hilarious and i
just
kept riding with it i shall allah are
you in the states as well
yeah yeah i'm in uh new jersey yeah
masha'allah so uh a white guy
in the states with a almost magazine
yeah exactly
all right i love bless you happy times
so uh we got a few comments in regards
to you
milham says god i love jake the
muslim alpha metaphysician wow i got
upgraded to alpha wow
and someone doubled down on that one
jake that oh wow
so how do you feel about red pill
terminology being used on you man
i don't know bro
you're in america so you can you can
plead the fifth yeah exactly
[Laughter]
all right so something i've been
wondering for a while is um
you're a reaver right yeah yeah masha
allah so your story because
many people revert masha'allah many
people when they revert you know they
they feel an urge to teach them to give
people the same kind of you know
blessing that they were given that you
know at one point in time they didn't
have which makes it all the more
powerful to them
but i don't think there's anyone you
know at least no one i can think of that
has taken the platform
that you have taken and has spoken about
things you've spoken about in the way
that you didn't know it sounds very
vague but a more philosophical approach
debating trinitarians debating
christians debating people who believe
jesus god and you know all these things
were more logical philosophical
perspective is something that i don't
see many reverts do so what i'm
wondering is
how did jake the muslim metaphysician
come to be
yeah so um
i mean specifically with with debating
christians and from a more philosophical
angle just because not everybody knows
who i am um i i have a background in
philosophy so i have a bachelor's degree
in philosophy and i'm trained
specifically in
analytic philosophy which is a type of
way of doing philosophy
and um actually i became a muslim when i
was in
college or at university so
when i was around 19 20 years old i
became a muslim
and i was i was studying philosophy and
one of the things that always bothered
me that never really made sense to me
when i was a catholic because i was
raised a roman catholic was a doctrine
of the trinity i never really believed
in it
this idea of three and one and one and
three never made sense to me like from a
simple perspective but because i was
studying philosophy at the time i said
well
and everybody else i wouldn't say
everybody but most people i think have a
similar experience where it's like the
trinity just doesn't make any sense
and um but i wanted to find a more
rigorous way
of saying that and explaining that so i
went on this quest of doing much more
research
and i i found that really i didn't have
to do much much research because even in
the
christian philosophical texts themselves
they explain exactly what the problem is
and they sort of
have done the work for me
and so yeah then i just went in a deep
dive into it and i've been reading a lot
of texts on christian theology and
philosophy classical text as well as on
contemporary text but long story short
or long story long the main reason why i
specifically got into that and with that
type of methodology is because it never
made sense to me but because of my
background and philosophy i wanted a way
to sort of
explain it in a rigorous detailed
fashion and so that's what kind of
launched me into studying that and then
since then um
i've been discussing and debating with
uh christian academics yeah
wow
i didn't know so you you decided to
study philosophy before even accepting
islam
yes yes wow wow
all right all right masha allah and i've
seen different debates different
discussions different arguments that
christians make there was one guy in
particular after i forget his name but
uh it was a debate i think
he also traveled to the uk uh to debate
a few people at speaker's corner james
white or uh
oh you're talking about josh
yes josh josh yeah yeah that that was
the first one that really stood out to
me because his argument i forgot what it
was now but
back then it kind of stumped me you know
i'm not a super i'm not a philosophy
major at all you know by no means so
someone like me you know that the kind
of argument is like oh you know that's
interesting then seeing him debate you
and discuss with you uh i was like wow
that's found a lot you know this guy on
the shoulder nobody's talking about so
yeah actually that's um
a little bit of a backstory i don't know
if i've mentioned this on um
camera at all but um
how i kind of got launched into debating
was i had my own youtube channel but i
wasn't really using it and uh you know i
was just doing my own studying on the
side
and people were bothering me bothering
me they're like jake you need to get
involved with your youtube channel make
some videos you know you have things
that uh people can benefit from and i
just was not i was just putting it off
for a while
and then
one of my friends contacted me along
with um
hashem from speaker's corner um who some
of the audience may be familiar with
hash from his good brother mashallah
from speaker's corner and basically long
story short josh was at speaker's corner
and
that maybe the same kind of experience
that you had some of the muslims were
having there as well because
whether we like it or not josh is a
smart guy even if he has a an incorrect
uh theology right he's done a phd on the
trinity so he's using a lot of
terminology that people may not be
familiar with
kind of maybe confusing people yeah and
so uh muslims in the park
were having um discussions with him but
maybe not always able to
really understand what he's saying or
find a way to tackle the issue so they
contacted me and they're like okay jake
we've got this guy josh i didn't know
who he was at the time um would you be
interested in debating him having a
debate with him and
i was like
yeah sure why not my first public debate
i'll just go and debate somebody who has
a phd on the subject
uh who's an expert in it and you know
who am i
um so yeah that was actually my first
introduction into the debate scene
and um
yeah i debated him once uh initially and
then we had a second debate which was
hosted on the sc dawa channel and then
since then i've just been debating uh
you know various scholars including uh
james white so
yeah
a lot
and if you guys haven't seen it go check
it out check out his other work on you
know the youtube channel the muslim out
of physician great great stuff masha
allah quick shout out to another great
youtube channel blogging theology paul
summer like um bro great to have you in
and if you look at the comments masha
allah people are very very happy to see
you here as well
yeah so oh paul's a friend too so uh
salaam to paul we speak uh you know now
and then and i i really enjoy his
channel it's definitely something i look
forward to watching his videos when they
come out masha allah so yeah yeah 100
100
beautiful brother allah so
going back to the trinity
do you find because something i i think
about allah and i think a lot of that is
uh i would say less
experienced that is when it comes to
debating the trinity they
think
or they ask themselves should i take a
philosophical approach historical
approach slash biblical approach and i
want to separate the two because not
everything that's historical is biblical
but the bible is technically you know
historical is it reliable or not
i'm not going to talk about it obviously
you must believe it's fully reliable
but
why is is it only because you studied
philosophy that you use philosophical
means to debate
or do you see some kind of value in it
that may be historical
documents or historical arguments can't
really provide
okay so yeah that's a good question um
so i just explained how i initially got
into it but besides that when i started
looking into it more and even when i was
doing some of my own research
i was trying to find other muslim
sources where i can see maybe are they
talking about it from a philosophical
angle has anybody really tackled it in
this way
and
unfortunately and a little bit to my
surprise i didn't really find that maybe
i've missed it and you know it could be
that i just didn't come across it but i
i did hear it you know in certain
debates
certain points would be made but not in
the way that i was sort of looking for
so another reason why i started going in
this direction and discussing and having
debates and in the way that i do is be
so because i saw a gap in the field you
know masha'allah we have we've had a lot
of um muslim debaters debating
christians and very knowledgeable on on
scripture but basically saying okay
here's your scripture uh it doesn't even
teach the trinity right so that's one
thing and going back and forth and
really knowing at times the bible better
than the christian debaters um so that
was done and so i was like really what
can i add to that discussion not very
much of anything um and then the second
point is and especially more recently
there has been a lot of
critique not only from muslims but from
christian scholarship or even some can
say skeptics like bart ehrman and others
uh attacking the
reliability or the transmission of the
text and so that was sort of taken care
of as well um but then i was looking for
at least somebody uh contemporary on the
contemporary scene to be doing that from
a philosophical or theological angle and
i didn't really see it in in the way
that i wanted so that's another reason
why
was i was attempting to try to uh fill
that gap
well anyway a gap that i saw
so um that's that's the second point of
why i kind of uh launched into it and
then a third reason is i do think that
um it is a it is a good approach not to
say that the other approaches are not
good i i see it as a supplementary
approach or things that can work
together it's not like oh you need to
have jake's approach or you need to have
like ahmedidat's approach i think they
can both go together i don't see any
reason why not so
um
so yeah
the other reason is i do think
that these philosophical or theological
questions that i raise and i think
objections to the trinity and things
like jesus being god and man at the same
time i do think they are very powerful
um sometimes they're complicated but i
try to do my best to make it simple to
say okay besides all this stuff this is
really what it boils down to and does
this make sense because my approach is
this and i sort of
when i speak to trinitarians or people
that believe jesus is god say listen
i'll grant you for the sake of argument
that jesus is god or that the the the
bible teaches that jesus is god let's
say the bible's reliable and the bible
teaches that jesus is god and he's the
second member of the trinity right
i still even if i re i don't believe
that that's true but even if i believed
it was true and i'm granting it for the
sake of argument i still wouldn't
believe in the trinity so an example i
give as i say even if it said in bold
letters on every page of the bible that
jesus is god or the trinity is true i
still wouldn't believe in it because it
just doesn't make any sense
and so that's kind of my approach or
where i'm coming from um because i saw
mashallah that all the other areas were
sort of covered as far as the
textual transmission and critical
analysis of the text as well as okay now
we even have the text but it doesn't say
what you guys are saying so i wanted to
add something additional and say okay
let's say the text is reliable let's say
grant you your interpretation that it is
saying that jesus is a member of the
trinity and he's god doesn't even make
sense guys no i don't think it does so
i'm still not going to accept it so yeah
that's kind of my uh approach
yeah and you know what you bring up a
very very interesting point especially
the one at the end there where you
mentioned even if it did say in the
bible you still wouldn't believe it
because it's something that doesn't make
sense it's a proposition that is a
contradiction inherently so for us to
believe it it's like why don't we
believe in married bachelor squared
circles and things like any
contradiction could be you know true
and
this leads me to my next question's
panel law which is that you know despite
it being such a blatant contradiction
like you know people make fun of like
things like uh you know flat earthers
right right it's not really they don't
have really philosophical beliefs or
even scientific beliefs empirical
beliefs but
the the discussion of earth being around
flying all is not a discussion for the
for the sake of you know my own sanity
and my own credibility it's not a
discussion but those who try and say the
earth is flat
you know it's a scientific discussion
it's not philosophical but people clown
on them for being so silly but when it
comes to christians there are so many
christians in the world that
wholeheartedly believe in
father son holy spirit equal eternal
partners or persons in one god which is
the trinity now
they try and justify this by saying you
can't ascribe our logic to god and limit
god with our logic and i think that this
is the main reason that even though they
don't understand it or can't possibly
comprehend such a contradiction they
still convince themselves that it is
true
even if they don't directly find it in
the bible so how would you counter that
kind of argument that you can't put god
in our logical box
yeah i mean i have a
i have a big problem with that right
because this is an example i like to
give you know um
i've i've been given some talks and uh
you know i gave i gave this as an
example to the audience you know imagine
i'm just sitting here now and i said you
know by the way guys i have a square
circle in my pocket i want to show it to
you right art are you even going to look
are you going to say
listen brother jake i know you've been
talking for probably the past 20 minutes
and everything you said
makes perfect sense thus far but i don't
know seems like you kind of went off the
deep end here i don't know
you would be like what's wrong with this
guy of course he did you won't even look
to see if i have a square circle in my
pocket we're just going to say somebody
get this guy a white coat or something
and
get him to a hospital so
um
likewise if i said you know i'm a
married bachelor right now and people
are going to say jake what are you
talking about you're married bachelor
doesn't mean it makes sense so
yeah
what i'm trying to show with that
analysis of saying do i have a square
circle i have a square circle in my
pocket are you going to look if you say
you're not even going to look and you
think that i'm crazy that shows
intuitively that you don't think
contradictions can exist in reality
therefore if i've concluded the doctrine
of the trinity or the doctrine of the
incarnation is that type of
nonsense i'm sorry to say i i don't mean
to be disrespectful but that type of
thing that just doesn't make any sense
well then i don't need to go further i
don't need to see well it's in the bible
or well you know this person said it or
no i i just in the same way i don't care
who told me that they had a square
circle i'm not going to look so um
that's sort of my approach now um
from a muslim paradigm as well we say
for example that allah subhanahu wa
he can do anything that's logically
possible right his power only attaches
to logical possibilities so when you ask
well like atheists sometimes ask these
kind of silly questions about well can
god create another god well no because
that's not a thing that god can't do
it's not even a thing because god by
definition is not creative so when you
say can god create another god you're
basically just like spewing nonsense
it's not even a coherent question you
see so in the same way
it's not a limitation on god because
it's not some it's not a thing that god
can't do
it's not a thing to begin with meaning a
contradiction is not a real thing so um
this is how i would approach it with
christians and the other thing too that
i would like them to think about is well
well if i turn around or i'm having a
discussion with a christian and i get
into a contradiction with my conception
of god i can just say well by the way
god is above logic um you know he can
appear to be contradictory or be
actually contradictory there's no
problem well now we're at an
intellectual stalemate how can we really
move anywhere in the conversation it's
like my position's contradictory and so
is yours
so what i mean
might as well just like pack up and go
home have a nice night so
yeah that's that's my response is that i
don't think they would accept that in in
a discussion with me and so likewise we
should be on equal playing ground
yeah and you know what that is a very
very great answer especially when you
look at a lot of i mean i'm on tick tock
so there's a lot of younger people on
there and a lot of the arguments they
make is oh why would god make it appear
that you know jesus was crucified why
would he do that and it's like if you
believe god can be a contradiction a
living contradiction why can't god you
know
like lie or something we don't believe
allah lies we
what's wrong with it you believe that
god is ever living and he died and that
he was he was never created but had a
birthday and all these different things
that are independent and dependent why
can't we believe that so that's a very
interesting points
and um
i had one other thing i want to talk
about but uh i forgot now so i'll move
on uh there's this
i think for the softball concept i'm
probably gonna butcher it but
dilethism where it's okay
yeah so i mean obviously you're familiar
with it yeah basically like
something we would see as a
contradiction but it's also true at the
same time something that's true and
false at the same time one example i was
given is like if someone's standing in
the doorway
people see him as being in the room and
outside the room and there's supposed to
be two contradicting statements that are
both true so i've never heard a
christian take this line of argument but
i've heard of dialethism recently so how
would you
respond to uh
people saying god can make a
contradiction
um yeah so there there actually is a
christian that um a christian scholar
that actually does take that position it
is to be fair to christians right it is
a minority view i'm just looking at my
phone because i'm seeing if i could
maybe pull up a quote from his book real
quick um but in the meantime
um so there's a christian scholar by the
name of jc beale and he actually
specializes in logic
and so he's a proponent of dialethism as
you mentioned which is basically the
idea
uh it's it's a non-standard or
non-classical logic
so usually
we would say that either proposition is
true or false
but dialethism says well no a
proposition can be
true and false simultaneously right and
so it's this idea that you can have true
contradictions basically and one of the
examples that they use um or that jc
beal uses
is um
something that's called the liar's
paradox right and so
it's
if it's confusing for people who haven't
heard it before but it's basically like
this sentence is false so if i say this
sentence is false well
is that true
well if it's true
then it's contradictory because it says
this sentence is false so then this
sentence is false is both true and false
at the same time and now we have a
contradiction right so they use these
type of like
what i would call semantic um
contradictions right um there are
responses to that that i don't think
necessitate that we accept it is a true
contradiction for example um there's
another position in which we could say
that that sentence is neither true nor
false meaning that it's it's vague when
we say this sentence what is it actually
referring to it doesn't seem to have a
referent and because it's vague we just
say it's neither true nor false uh it's
not true and false at the same time it's
neither true nor false so um but j.c
beal uses this example and then he goes
from that which even if we granted let's
say for the sake of argument liar's
paradox you can't solve it it's true and
false at the same time it's
contradictory how do you get from that
to a contradiction in reality in other
words that's a contradiction that is
purely linguistic or semantic it's just
like writing on a piece of paper but
it's not something that
exists in physical reality or even in
metaphysical reality so how are you
going from that to a contradiction in
reality like in physical reality and
then from there a concert god himself
being a contradiction it's like whoa you
went from this little linguistic problem
which i think there are other solutions
to it to
all the way up to god at the top
being literally a contradiction and it's
like whoa
subhanallah slow down why do we go all
the way there you know so um yeah i i
it's it's not a common uh thing
but
jc beale there could be others but he's
the first christian that i've seen
that's really trying to go
in that direction as far as um utilizing
it for problems with the trinity and uh
christology
yeah well i found a lot i want to look
more into that inshallah because it is
very interesting yeah have you made a
video on it or will we make a video on
it
um i i haven't really made a video on it
yet um
i i don't think
yeah i don't think i specifically
addressed it just because they're
they're not that many people that
actually hold that view and christians
when i have mentioned j.c beal when i
have mentioned jc beale like christians
usually get upset because like come on
jake it's just one guy right but yeah
i'm like yeah but he's kind of got a
point because
to be fair what he's saying
he's basically saying look we've been
trying to solve these problems for the
past 2000 years
nobody's been able to solve it we've got
this dialethism anyway
and let's just take that and then apply
it to god and jesus christ
and it's like well i don't know uh jc
you're going really far very quickly but
let me just read actually quickly a
passage from his book
uh where where he mentions this uh one
second here
so he has a book which is literally
actually called the contradictory christ
so that's the name of the book and what
he's saying
so um he says here
the the quest to consistentize christ or
basically to make christ a consistent
being
the quest to give a consistent solution
to what richard cross in 2011
famously dubbed the fundamental problem
of christology which is basically what
you were saying before
jesus is fully god and fully man at the
same time how can it be necessary and
contingent at the same time eternal and
created at the same time all powerful
and weak and so on and so on that's
basically the problem
he says it enjoys a long and fascinating
history and the quest continues in full
force up through today basically saying
look it goes all the way back to the
beginning it's not a new problem and it
still goes up to today but he says this
this is his thesis now but i believe
that the quest should end
i believe that christian thinkers should
accept the contradiction of christ so
wow he's just saying look let's just
accept it and now he goes on further
christ is a contradictory being so goes
the central thesis of this book
at the crux of christian theology is a
contradiction
namely christ jesus is a being of whom
some claims are both true and false
that's it so that's the thesis of his
book is to say look
this problem has been since the birth of
christianity right and when people were
saying that jesus was fully god and
fully man
fourth and fifth centuries
all the way up to today
and nobody solved it guys just accept
that christ is literally a contradiction
a contradictory being and so then he
goes on in the rest of the book to try
to explain that but yeah that's uh he's
the only one that i've really seen go
down that path
well
i mean at least at least he's trying
like at least he recognizes it at least
it's honest uh yeah i'll say this
because
you know what he does a good job of
brother in in the rest of the book you
know people can take shots at them him
whatever
he tries to steal man the other like
proposed solutions to the problem and he
says okay here's the problem here's how
you guys have tried to solve it but
here's why it doesn't work and so he's
showing in the book
look say what you want about my view but
none of you have solved anything you see
so i think at least his book is is a
good um source for that because you can
kind of see how him who is a christian
he does believe in it but he just thinks
it's contradictory right
and it's primarily because nobody's been
able to solve these problems
yeah yeah 100 and you mentioned that
church fathers recognize these problems
and they had many different
uh concoctions of you know the trinity
and of god yeah as a whole you know uh
there is a subordinationism
separationism uh modalism and eventually
trinitarianism which uh i guess stuck uh
but not i i would say you know one isn't
really better than the other none of
them make sense at all but at least at
least he's trying he says you know
there's a problem recognized it tries to
solve it i mean clearly it's i would say
a bit of a false equivalency to take
the uh the statement and turn it into
okay therefore a being you know can
operate and exist in the same manner and
it reminds me of an argument i heard
once about
um the contingency argument like the
necessary existence
part of me they tried to kind of
disprove that the necessary existence
needs to be or something like that using
necessary facts
and obviously a fact is not like
existence and you mentioned semantics
linguistic semantics are not like
things that actually exist in the
physical world or in reality
and i think that's very very important
um because philosophy can really really
um you know
uh break some hearts i'd say lower yeah
and shatter some people's brains
sometimes and uh you know if that
happens you hit hit uh you know our man
jake up here
yeah yeah yeah it is something and i
know that some people have been
concerned about it it is something that
um
um
it takes careful consideration i don't
think anybody should just be launching
themselves into it uh you should have a
good foundation
you know on the fundamentals of your
dean
before you really start diving into any
of this stuff and really
the only reason i have
done it
is primarily to combat uh what i believe
are false beliefs um not really to so
much build up um like i don't inject it
into islam or anything like that
it's mainly a language in a way to
speak to other people who don't accept
the quran and the sunnah you see um so
yeah but um definitely
it could take you down some rabbit holes
and uh all of a sudden you're like whoa
how did i get here so yeah yeah yeah for
sure i mean when you look at kind of
western academia and where it's gotten
today when you look at even science and
philosophy you'll notice that both of
them when muslims try and use them
wholeheartedly you know could take them
down you know a bit of a
a bit of a dark path eventually because
they'll get in science to get to things
like evolution and they'll find that
science literally will never even
mention god because as soon as they
mention oh god did this it's like okay
that's god of the gaps science is aimed
its aim is to understand the universe
and how it works and if they implement
god then you know go out of the gaps
it's not going to work and with
philosophy
it's uh it it's very easy to go wrong
especially if you don't know what you're
doing um so when you know when people
make up some kind of logical argument
that has a bad premise or the logic
isn't fully sound um but it's hard for
you know lay men like me to pick it up
you know it does shatter hearts and if
you look at you know people who try and
say that philosophy is not allowed or
yeah philosophy is not allowed in islam
logical arguments aren't is not allowed
in islam
uh i mean i would put that in the same
boat as science because you know the
earliest muslims weren't sitting around
using science to prove islam but people
do it nowadays and people don't really
seem to have much of a problem with that
compared to philosophy
but both of them have been used
immensely
used it and just for people who want to
kind of
get mad at that
it was used by scholars and uh
yeah i mean even eben tamiya for example
he used
a version of the contingency argument
and you know
from his approach and which i agree with
um the concept of the fitrah that we
have this innate disposition to know and
believe in allah subhanahu wa
which i agree with but what happens is
over time the what he said the fit sort
of gets clouded right and so it lacks
that sort of recognition so what you
sometimes need and he actually says
sometimes is needed for some people you
actually have to give them rational or
ugly arguments in order to show
and sort of reawaken that fit and now
now all of a sudden they can see things
uh more clearly so it's a tool
that's used to get to a certain end but
um yeah of course you have to approach
things differently there's not a one
size fits all in dalla and and this is
what i say all the time to people like
um
for some people my approach may work uh
when i'm speaking to christians or
atheists other people another approach
might work and even myself
i adapt like when i see and i'm speaking
to someone i'm like okay this is not
gonna work i might go a different route
so um yeah it's not like a one size fits
all we have to try to accommodate to the
person that we're speaking to uh in the
best way that we can yeah yeah yeah
that's very beautifully said masha'allah
and it's very it's very wise as well
because even the prophet islam
in some cases you could see he says
things that he wouldn't say to everyone
or he doesn't say to everyone and in
some cases he actually doesn't say
anything
and i think you know that's evidence
that as you said we should be wise when
we speak to people and kind of um play
the tune in the room whatever they need
give it to them and unfortunately since
we're on the topic a lot of days fall
into the problem of giving dawah how
they want to give dawah and not giving
daba how the person they're talking to
other people they're talking to need to
receive it so i think that's beautifully
said and if you read the quran allah i
wouldn't say that you know this is
really the attempt or the motive but
allah
revealed some verses that can be seen as
kind of a logical argument
he says were they created from nothing
he poses the question which gets you to
think logically and it's asked in a way
where it's like you immediately know
that is not possible that's a
contradiction or were they themselves
the creators of themselves again another
contradiction
or did they create the heavens and the
earth again something that doesn't make
sense because we were created within the
earth upon the earth so all these things
that you know cause us to use our logic
or at least i'll say our intuition
you know subhanallah really really do
awaken the the fitzra for hopefully a
lot of people alhamdulillah but i want
to bring it back
to something because i remember what i
was going to say like 20 minutes ago
when it comes to contradictions you
mentioned that you're you're saying i
don't know if you use the word gibberish
but something that basically doesn't
make sense yeah and i basically
literally just wanted to say if i were
to just spew out a bunch of random
noises nothing something that's
completely unintelligible
that would correct me from wrong that
would be the same thing as saying
something that's a contradiction because
not have any intellectual value at all
even as even in the english language
yeah all right exactly
yeah yeah it would just be like me
spewing nonsense that it's really
unintelligible because i mean when
you're talking about square circle or
married bachelor any of these kind of
things it's it's just as if i just was
saying
what are you talking about it doesn't it
has no meaning
or reference like when you bring these
things together it just doesn't make any
sense so
um yeah bro that's
that's the reality
uh you did what i didn't have the
bravery to do which was actually spew
random noise
yeah well you guys got me now so one
shot lamela bless you bro
so i had we got this question a little
while ago they asked and i think you
answered this in your articulation of
one one of your answers to my questions
before
but kept the necessary being be a trying
god
oh yeah so it's interesting this
question because um just on uh we had an
episode yesterday on on a podcast show
that i'm part of tap thought adventure
podcast we had a christian guest on
who's happens actually to be an expert
on the contingency argument
and
i didn't bring up the trinity myself um
he actually brought up the trinity on
his own towards the end of the
conversation it was mainly we were
talking on points of agreement
contingency argument and things related
to it and so all of a sudden he brings
up the
the trinity
but interestingly enough what he
actually said was
the the contingency argument gets you to
the existence of the father alone
not the son and the spirit why
because the contingency argument says
that there's one
foundational being
and who's independent but yet in
classical um trinitarianism
the son and the spirit are dependent on
the father
this goes to what you find in the nicene
creed that the son is eternally begotten
of the father and that basically what
that means is that he's eternally
dependent upon the father and the father
is not dependent on him so we're talking
about like foundational the father is is
more foundational than a son of spirit
and so in that sense
they don't qualify as the the necessary
being or the most fundamental being and
even josh himself has agreed with it
basically saying that his own research
leads to if we want to have the simplest
explanation
it's the father and then you get the i
mean of course from his perspective you
get the son the spirit from revelation
or things of that nature but it's not
based on the contingency argument so
yeah i would say that the contingency
argument is compatible with islam or in
a christian paradigm of course we don't
call god father but the father and i
think it necessarily sort of excludes uh
the son of the spirit but of course that
i'll have to go into into much more
detail on that yeah very beautiful
answer masha allah so when it comes to
the trinity
uh it depends on how the christian views
it
yeah
if they if they believe that the son is
also
i mean i
it depends i mean what did he believe
that the son is eternal but still came
from the father
yes yes so he believes that the son is
eternal but he he's eternally dependent
upon the father and basically what he
said is
it doesn't make sense to posit the
father son and spirit as all
foundational because now you have three
necessary beans yeah and no pun intended
but there's no need to have an
additional two necessary beans so what
he's saying is you have one necessary or
foundational being which is the father
and then the son of spirit are eternal
but they're dependent upon the father
now of course
if if that's the case then we would just
say sorry then the son of spirit can't
be god because god is not dependent he's
a samad he's uh independent he's the
being in which everything depends and he
doesn't depend on anything
um but yeah so that would be our
pushback in that direction you know
yeah one hundred percent one hundred
percent zach lucker very amazing answer
uh i'm
in a bit of a dilemma now i guess i have
to do it my little brother gave a super
chat but he wanted to shout out his own
site so
an endorsement this is a
self-endorsement by himself
guys don't do that to me again uh
i won't share your comment uh but i'll
take the money
[Laughter]
uh all right all right and we are gonna
have to end this one unfortunately i do
have a muggle rip uh it's going to end
soon but um what i did want to ask we
talked a lot about christianity
trinitarianism and and philosophy in
general but i want to ask about atheism
in regards to philosophy do you use
philosophy to debate atheists do you
find that atheists use the philosophy to
try and disprove god
yeah yeah so
um it depends on the atheist but a lot
of times i do
uh because
and especially on the channel that i
just mentioned so i have two youtube
channels since you know what since the
guy just plugged himself with throwing
in the super chat i must do it myself so
i have my own youtube channel muslim
metaphysician but then i have a separate
one which i'm a part of with three other
muslims not this three muslim channel
with three other muslims right and um
and we mainly saw my channel i mainly
focus on christianity but then on the
other channel that i'm a part of with uh
three other brothers we mainly focus on
atheism and specifically tackling it
from a secular perspective whether it be
from philosophical and mainly
philosophical we delve into science a
bit as well but in reality yes i do use
it and we do use things like the
contingency argument um the kalam
cosmological argument uh other arguments
because the reality is if i just go up
to some of these atheists it's not all
of them so it depends and we say okay by
the way the quran says that allah exists
and you are to serve and worship him
alone and not all any partners and
like well i don't believe in god so
you're bringing me a book that is
already assuming that god exists because
it's a book from god you need to prove
to me that god exists first so they say
okay all right sit down soldier and then
we you know we try to explain to them
that god exists and here's how we know
that god exists right so um
there are various ways to do it um you
brought up the verses in the quran which
which point to a type of rational
argument to say look where did all this
come from you did you create yourself
you know like it's kind of just pointing
to this direction that doesn't make any
sense except to admit that there is a
creator so yeah i do see the benefit in
that and we do delve into it especially
on tap uh thought adventure podcast
and um
we don't want to just deal with the
common guy in the street see me when i'm
i'm debating people whether it be
christian or atheist we want the top guy
okay we want the top like we wanted the
top guy who's the scholar has done the
phd on the trinity we want the the guy
who's done a phd on us you know
disproving or objections to god's
existence or whatever it is and the
atheist side
and so that's that's what our our goal
is because
the way i see it is look if we can
handle the top guys if
defeat them or at least show that look
you guys aren't superior to us we can we
can stand our ground with you guys
then i think it provides um confidence
to muslims it allows them to see look
islam is very rich uh tradition uh
theologically and um
many other aspects spiritually as well
so we we have everything we don't need
to go to these other things to get these
other things like red pill you know i
know they called me alpha but
but so yeah
um you know th this this idea um
of atheism of course i think sometimes
it needs uh with certain atheists
unfortunately to talk to them from a
rational or scientific perspective
because their fitrah has been clouded it
needs to be awakened in some manner and
so we try to do it any way we can of
course we don't neglect the quran of
course we believe that the quran maybe
then picking up and reading it could
touch them because at the end of the day
allah subhanahu wa is the one who guides
not us we're just a tool that we we try
to do our best for him to use us
even though we're kind of a twisted tool
in a way but um so yeah uh of course
it's the same thing with atheists we try
to use rational argumentation to show
them look there's a creator and
creation um needs to worship that
creator and him alone and not any other
partners so we try to go into that and
um yeah we do the best we can
may allah reward you all for your work
i mean so you guys heard it here first
check out tap thought adventure podcast
the second realest podcast in the dunya
[Music]
i have a question but before i get to it
i do want to say um
this is not something that is scholarly
as far as i know i didn't get it from a
scholar i'm a layman with just making a
layman observation but when you look at
you know allah when he sent the
messengers he sent them with the message
and with ayat with proof with evidence
miracles and if you look at the type of
miracles they got in certain cases like
um musa alayhi salaam he went and he had
the staff that turned to a snake
this was something the magicians tried
to compete with
and you know his his snake ate up the
all the false snakes basically
so allah gave him a miracle that
basically was so obvious to the people
based on those magicians because that's
what people were doing magic islam he
healed the blind in the leper and so on
and so forth because medicine was you
know relatively popular at that time and
the prophet saws with the quran brought
something that walid ibn muhirah said as
a top poet he said it's not from
muhammad sallallahu i can't compete with
that and i'm the best and he literally
testified that um to his his little
posse of the so-called elites of quraysh
very terrible death by the way so
may allah protect me
so
kind of tearing towards what people what
people need or a person needs there's
nothing wrong with it if you read the
quran then you could see that maybe
that's what you know allah alludes to
us you know doing or what we should do
and uh there is one more thing i wanted
to mention uh
i can't remember the second time today
man angel does this all the time and i
guess since he's not here someone has to
do it so uh
i'm forgetting a lot now but uh
my question was you mentioned both the
contingency and the kalam cosmological
argument right
i remember muhammad hijab mentioned that
he uses a contingency argument because
the kalam cosmological argument
a lot of the time it ends up in in a
kind of debate on infinity total
infinity versus positive infinity and
the difference and all this stuff
and you know i had one or two debates
about it using that line of argument or
i would say i used the contingency
argument in a way which
relied on
uh
kind of the infinity argument
and because of that it turned into an
argument about infinity um and so when i
heard him say that i was like you know
that's very true so i kind of teared the
way i used it uh to make it a little
easier to digest and harder to review so
would you say that the
that one would be better than the other
that they're both equal
um
so i mean my personal position is i
think that the contingency argument is a
stronger argument
um
but again the issue is the contingency
argument in a sense this is my personal
opinion you know so take it for what
it's worth contingency argument tends to
be a bit more philosophical and
um not as easily accessible to the
layman i think whereas the kalam
cosmological argument i think the reason
why
it's been so popular especially recently
is that it's
very easy to understand in a sense you
don't need to explain contingency and
necessity and getting into this and that
it's less whatever begins to exist as a
cause the universe began to exist
therefore it had a cause it see it's
easy to picture you know
so um
sometimes when i it's somebody that i
know
really doesn't understand the
philosophical language that well i i
more so lean towards the kalam argument
uh but in terms of what i think is
actually stronger argument uh i would
say that contingency argument yeah
okay okay
yeah that was more so a personal
question i wasn't thinking like the
viewers would benefit from when i was
just i'm being selfish
all right so
i was gonna do kind of a calling at the
end we don't have time for that
unfortunately maybe insha'allah i'm very
hopeful that jake the muslim
metaphysician will be back
um maybe next week maybe for the next
live i hope very soon
and we can do some kind of a calling
because he does that all the time not
looking to debate anyone you know but
yeah that's what i was going to say
um i was going to mention i i feel you
when it when it comes to obviously i'm
not
i i don't think that someone like
william lane craig should ever debate
someone like me because i'm not at that
level yet right so when i say this i say
in the most humble way possible
but
i've debated people atheists um and and
christians i'd say that
i'll just put it like this there's a
debate against a guy named mike on the
three muslims uh podcast and i don't
recommend anyone watch it and the reason
i don't is not because like i did badass
on it actually i think i did very good
it's because the stuff he said is just
so hard to listen to like it's so hard
to watch because of him uh in the
beginning he said that uh
basically he said that you can't we
shouldn't use logic
at all
and it's like how did you come to that
conclusion logically or
what so
just because of that i i i feel you 100
that when you debate someone needs to
debate someone with a certain
level of of understanding a certain
level of knowledge and i would say a
certain level of respect as well because
you know last thing we want is for
someone to come on and just start
you know swearing cursing or anything
like that because they get caught up in
a you know
a rock and a hard hard spot basically
yeah yeah yeah um there was somebody
earlier in the chat if i could just say
one last thing before you close out that
was asking me a question they didn't
send it as a super chat but they were
asking me do i have any resources on the
early church fathers what they believed
in their theology
well interestingly enough and i'll send
it to you in the back chat if if you
want to post a link to it you can
um
interestingly enough i just came out
with a course on sapience institute
which is called the christological
controversies it has 28 episodes there's
like 12 hours worth of material so
it's pretty in depth and um in that
course in the first i think 13 or 14
episodes i'm primarily going through the
church fathers i go through primary
source material okay saint um irenaeus
said this uh augustine said this this
was his position and i start from the
earliest going from clement of rome and
polycarp up through justin martyr
all the way up to origin to the
up until the fourth century and i show
that nobody prior to the council of
nicaea these great church fathers who
are respected by christians and the
christian tradition none of them
actually they weren't muslims
necessarily but none of them believed in
the doctrine of the trinity as was
conceived in the fourth century so
that's a resource that you guys can take
a look at and just a quick plug not only
my um
class on there but there are plenty of
other classes on there on the sapience
institute learning uh platform and uh
you guys may be able to benefit for that
but for that specific question would be
to go to this course where i have a lot
of material uh breaking that down and
all the power points and references are
are available you can download them and
so people will have that there inshallah
insha allah very beautifully beautifully
said mashallah we have a
testimony here from land cruiser guy
masha allah saying i'm in iranian
episode i believe that's how you say it
amazing
so we have it right here on allah uh
best of the best and bro honestly it's
so beautiful seeing you know how many
muslims there are out there doing the
work how many institutions we have how
many websites we have how many courses
we have how many youtube channels we
have that are completely free just for
educating people uh and yeah that's a
good thing to mention it's free guys
sorry
yes it's free it's free and everyone
loves free inshallah especially when
it's knowledge alhamdulillah so may
allah reward you and everyone the sacred
institute
i mean the work they do there is is
tremendous phenomenal
and uh it's it's very very needed
alhamdulillah so with that being said
unfortunately we do have to end the live
i do have to get going here uh i will
post a link to it in the description if
you guys are too lazy to uh you know
find it yourself so you can find it
there inshallah check it out check out
tap
uh thought adventure podcast and check
out the muslim metaphysician on his
youtube channel and with that being said
everyone for attending this beautiful
live it's been amazing uh well 108
viewers need you all to like the video
now
for jake's uh maga looking hat
and with that being said
foreign